bonsoir bienvenue au conseil régional de
bourgogne franche comté où les élus sont
actuellement toujours réunis en
assemblée plénière une cession
importante qui a marqué la fin de la
période de transition après la fusion
puisque les élus ont adopté une
organisation territoriale pour la région
à une large majorité ils ont répondu oui
à la proposition de la présidente dijon
sera la capitale le chef lieu avec la
préfecture de région et besançon
accueillera le siège du conseil régional
c'est vous qui avez vous lu cet
équilibre marie-guite dufay bonsoir et
merci d'avoir quitté la séance quelques
minutes
alors avant de discuter je vous propose
de revenir en images sur les débats avec
ce reportage de christophe taris et
amélie doux et 79 pour 18 contre 2
abstentions votre capital pour une union
en bourgogne franche comté le chef-lieu
sera dijon ainsi que dix sept directions
régionales le siège lui à besançon avec
douze directions
après plusieurs semaines de querelles
entre les deux villes la répartition est
désormais actée marie-guite dufay a pu
compter sur une majorité unifiée hormis
deux abstentions du prg des étudiants
très partielle des rapports entre deux
visions et que les débats à ce niveau là
ait pris autant d'importance au
détriment
du côté de l'opposition la droite a fait
entendre de voix si j'ai lu dont alain
joyandet ont ainsi voté pour 17 autres
s'y opposant le chef de file françois
sauvadet se demandant notamment où
étaient les économies tout cela aboutit
à une forme de de compromis dont
j'observe qui ne satisfait personne qui
constitue à l'évidence à rendez-vous
manqué avec l'avenir
imaginez madame la présidente vous nous
proposez besançon comme siège de la
région et vous préciser dans ce même
rapport que c'est un siège où personne
ne siégera je crois c'est un phénomène
unique au monde
le front national a lui voté dans sa
totalité pour cette nouvelle répartition
afin de rétablir un équilibre entre les
territoires et avait très clairement la
volonté pour une partie des élus
dijonnais d'aspirer d'aspirer tour à
dijon pour que c'est pas possible dans
une dans le cadre de la réalisation de
cette fusion il faut respecter les uns
les uns et les autres les francs comtois
sont pas là uniquement pour boucher les
trous
du budget régional et les dettes des
brugnons fait une nouvelle épreuve du
feu qu'a passé marie-guite dufay malgré
une séance parfois houleuse
la nouvelle organisation impulsée par la
présidente est désormais inscrite dans
le marbre que se donne le ton alors
marine
marie-guite dufay ce soir vous pousser
un ouf de soulagement c'est ce n'était
vraiment pas gagner votre majorité
n'était pas très soudé au débat au
départ nous avons eu des débats mais le
propre du la démocratie c'est quand même
bien de débattre et effectivement il y
avait on peut dire des oppositions
territoriale entre dijon et besançon
nous avons débattu nous nous sommes
rencontrés à maintes reprises et je suis
contente que une posture dans ma
majorité régionale les emporter sur des
postures territoriale alors vous dites
les maires un des deux grandes villes
dijon et besançon ont fait pression une
pression très forte quand même
et comme dirait monsieur souhaité mais
ce sont là des lui disais que c'était
des arrangements de coin de table
oui alors il n'y a ni de pression ni
d'un heureusement de coin de table
pression je sais pas ce que ça veut dire
bien et l'autre aurait souhaité que le
siège soit dans leur ville
si c'est ça que vous appelez faire
pression ils m'ont fait comprendre
qu'effectivement le trahir au pôle en
balance je siège était naturellement
chez l'un ou chez l'autre et moi j'ai
poursuivi mon idée que j'ai depuis deux
ans déquilibre d'équilibré territorial
c'est une conception que j'aurai pour
l'ensemble de l'aménagement de notre
territoire et il faut reconnaître contre
dijon et besançon il y a un petit sujet
besançon perd sa préfecture
besançon perd son statut de capitale
régionale il y a des signes à donner à
besançon est pour moi le signe c'est cet
équilibre entre la préfecture à dijon et
le siège de l'hôtel de région à besançon
sans les sessions à besançon ni les
réunions de commission ni la commission
permanente est ce que sera prête une
coquille vide quand même la loi juste
pour le symbole mais la loi bad pas du
tout la loi elle même dit qu'on ne peut
pas tout mettre au même endroit donc il
nous fallait bien dissocier
nous n'avons pas de siège d'assemblée à
besançon il aurait fallu faire des
travaux dans notre hémicycle
puis le bon sens c'est quand même que
les élus surtout ceux qui viennent de
loin de la nièvre et de l'yonne
une plutôt siéger à disons qu'à besançon
après comment peut-on dire que le siège
de besançon est une coquille vide
quand on voit qu'il va accueillir douze
directions comme dijon en accueille 17
donc c'est un équilibre conforme au
poids de la population et 12 direction
parmi lesquels des directions
opérationnelles très lourdes très forte
l'économie l'emploi la formation
l'orientation les transitions
professionnelles la transition
énergétique les lycées et on parle de
coquille vide
mais de quoi parle-t-on mais arrêtons je
n'ai cessé d'entendre des choses mais
vraiment faux si on l'avait dit en ces
lignes simplement un dernier mot vous
considérez que c'est une victoire
politique personnelle pour vous avec 79
voix pour ce texte
ensuite considéré jamais que c'est une
victoire personnelle il ya vraiment
c'est un travail d'équipé
c'est vraiment un travail d'équipé et
j'ai toujours dit je leur dis que je
suis fier de la majorité avec laquelle
je travaille c'est une vraiment très
belle majorité pleines dents vie parce
que je crois une équipe très renouvelée
merci beaucoup et la cession se poursuit
jusqu'en début de soirée ici au conseil
régional
merci eric conte 38 retrouver sur notre
site internet
ok